today we're going to be speaking with
Joe Berkowitz a writer whose work has
been featured in vulture the New Yorker
Fast Company he's author of The book's
American cheese and Away with words and
also of the recent article when did the
F your feelings crowd get so triggered
Joe really great having you on I
appreciate your time
thanks for having me so I mean maybe to
start you know it's it's increasingly as
the American right wing and Republican
party has gotten away from serious
policy discussions there has been more
and more of a focus on this idea of
owning the libs triggering the
snowflakes
Etc almost as a stand-in for policy
where they they almost seem to see it as
virtuous for its own sake if if Liberals
are angry then we must be doing
something right at the same time they
have this phrase facts don't care about
your feelings which often comes up in in
right-wing media Etc did this all start
because they started losing American
public opinion on policy or what are the
origins of this shift that we've seen
foreign
I think
uh there is a resentment about uh not
having more standing in culture
I think
um just seeing how kind of
the liberal bias of entertainment uh I
think it's calmed down a little bit at
least but looking back at 2016 it was
pretty rampant if you look at
the the Clinton campaign you know
leaning on people like like Lena Dunham
and things like that it was just I look
back now and I can sort of see where
some of the resentment may have come
from
but I do feel there's resentment of uh
from conservatives about feeling like
they didn't have a place in culture uh
and
that uh kind of LED in my opinion to the
uh trolling as politics and which you
know saw its uh hypothesis in um in the
ascent of Donald Trump in 2016. one of
the interesting
um hypocrisies is that while on the one
hand there is this F your feelings sort
of idea from the right it's that they
also engage in much of that same well
this just feels wrong sort of
argumentation just to pick one example
and there's so many right the entire
drag show stuff where children are being
recruited and forced and
groomed and it's you know for the most
part kids are showing up at any kind of
drag event if their parents have made
the choice to bring them there nobody's
being recruited nobody's being forced
but they just feel as though it's very
much wrong and we could talk about a lot
of these different arguments talk a
little bit about that and and the idea
that it is also an instance sort of of a
projection that they say uh we don't
care about your feelings we care about
facts and yet so many of the arguments
they do make are based simply on their
feelings
yeah a lot of what we're seeing now uh
is all feelings based uh backlash and I
think
um
it's it's probably
best uh exemplified by you know the uh
the the backlash to the the Bud Light
campaign and the and Target and things
like that uh I saw a tweet after my
article came out
and it was Charlie Kirk from
um Turning Point USA yeah surprisingly a
lot of cloud I guess uh yeah shockingly
people even though it's sort of Youth
centered but it seems like only old
people seem to listen to it but anyway
Charlie Kirk uh tweeted that I opened my
fridge the other day and I didn't know
whether my ketchup was woke or my
mustard was woke and it sounds like a
parody yeah but he was being 100 serious
and I think I'm not sure if I put this
in the article or not but like somebody
was saying I heard that Chick-fil-A got
a Dei uh vice president or a just a high
up person just just strictly for Dei
he's like does that mean I have to
boycott Chick-fil-A I like Chick-fil-A
and so it's this feeling like we have to
uh push back against these things even
though they're not
I mean there's no effect on your life if
uh
Bud Light sends a beer to a trans
influencer I I I really I've racked my
brain and I can't see how that affects
anyone in any ways but there is livid
outrage uh there is Kid Rock ticking an
automatic weapon and shooting a bunch of
Bud Light
which I suppose is supposed to exemplify
it's supposed to show strength I don't
know how that shows strength but anyway
and yeah so these are all feelings this
isn't a policy that they have a a
logical rebuttal to this is just
I know that in my heart that it is bad
for uh lgbtq representation
to be to appear in the corporate world
doesn't need to have a corporate
sanction that is against what I stand
for and I am furious about it in my
heart
one of the um
themes with a lot of these culture
issues is using kids as a sort of shield
in a way or not even a shield it's not a
scapegoat it's sort of like saying kids
are the victims and if you go back 10
years when I was covering the fight for
um for marriage equality you would hear
about no gay gay men are grooming kids
and they are pedophiles and so on and so
so forth now you're seeing it with trans
people now you're seeing it with the
drag shows uh when it came to masks and
vaccines it was the kids the kids can't
breathe and the vaccines aren't safe for
the kids and the kids aren't getting a
say and then it's well uh for when it
comes to don't say gay and the AP
History Class in Florida it's kids are
being taught to hate America or whatever
the case may be this is this is a theme
right I mean at this point the the use
of kids is the victims who we have to
protect seems like a clear-cut strategy
yeah
um you know with the don't say gay
initiative they promised it was just to
protect children and then of course they
did start doing it for uh middle school
and I believe high school students uh
but they did start raising the age yeah
and it was pretty clear they just wanted
to get it out of school and
I I do believe they want to protect
children but I think they're lying about
who they want to protect them from they
say they want to protect them from
predators but what I think they want to
protect them from is the possibility
that they'll think it's okay to be gay
that they that they'll learn that if
they feel as though they were born in
the wrong body that there are
possibilities to explore that they don't
they want to protect them from even a
chance of that they would rather uh have
them you know be uh suppressed
suppressed and go back to before that
was uh sanctioned culturally at all so
they want to protect them from reality
and then it's even more egregious with
the the black history stuff
um I used as an example in the piece the
idea of protecting children from
learning uh how Jackie Robinson was
treated uh when he what became the first
black major baseball player yeah but um
that may be a slightly exaggerated
example I don't even think so I mean
just the kinds of things that they want
to pretend protect children from feeling
uh weird or guilty about it's uh it's
ludicrous uh especially after all the
talk about six years ago when Trump was
first you know uh becoming present uh
about safe spaces yeah you uh they're
just uh
ill-preparing children uh from finding
out hard truth later on if they just
want to paint a whitewashed portrait of
history for them now
what do you think or do you have an
opinion when it comes to the strategy
that the left should adopt because when
it comes to a lot of these cultural
issues you can find arguments all over
the map you can find arguments that say
the the left should completely ignore
every single one of these issues you
know androgynous M M's that Tucker
Carlson's no longer attracted to it's
like just don't just don't even weigh in
don't even acknowledge that they are
doing these things another view is
fight them on each of the issues on the
merits make the case about the M Ms make
the case about AP History but like fight
it on the merits for each one third
option expose the hypocrisy as you were
talking about they claim to be about
against safe spaces but they're
essentially creating them through some
of these policies they claim to be
against feelings-based uh uh policy
proposals but it's exactly what they're
doing right so that would be like a
third option focus on the hypocrisy do
you have an opinion as to what the best
approach would be for the left on this
I remember right when uh Biden right
after the inauguration he was just uh or
at least his administration anyway was
coming out with uh fulfilling campaign
promises left and right they were just
kind of heads down getting the work done
and if you look back at the Articles at
that time that was when uh
Eminem's are woke uh and what was it oh
yeah the Dr Seuss books that was just
the those were the major issues and they
were ignored uh in favor of passing
legislation or there was just no
messaging on the left really about it
and that seemed to work but that's not
an election that's just getting stuff
done I think last year uh the midterms
they were set up to be a referendum on a
lot of these uh culture War type issues
true and I think in addition to having
weak candidates I think what we've
learned is that a lot of people who
aren't on Twitter for the entirety of
the day or listening to whatever is to
the right of Fox News oan or Newsmax or
whatever
those people don't care about that stuff
or
and I think or at least a majority seem
to have you know bigger concerns uh you
know like
inflation seemed to be abandoned for
Trans athletes in a lot of these
campaigns
um
so I do think
um that a good strategy I've seen a
couple politicians
uh do this is just kind of
point out how weird this stuff is
like uh I forget which state I should
have prepared a little bit but uh either
Tennessee or just some one state wanted
to have genital inspections oh yeah
student athletes to make sure uh that
they're uh they're the uh gender they
were assigned at Birth and that's that's
pretty creepy especially for the people
who are constantly pointing out like
beware of creepy people like
um so yeah I think
uh trying to debate that might be a
losing issue because you're not going to
dissuade someone from from uh their
claims that that trans people shouldn't
have rights or uh black history
shouldn't be taught in schools you can't
dissuade someone about that you can't
defeat them doesn't matter if you have
the facts uh
people you're not going to convince
someone who's uh livelihood depends on
on being confidently wrong so just point
out how weird it is and move on that
seems to be a winning strategy for uh
some politicians I've seen I I certainly
agree with that at least from what I've
seen so far we've been speaking with Joe
Berkowitz about his article when did the
F your feelings crowd get so triggered
we're going to be linking to the article
Joe I really appreciate your time and
insights today
well thanks for adding me on David it
was a pleasure